This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Let's say you lived sometime before 1860 and you wanted to fire a rifle. First, you'd need to pour gunpowder into the powder charge to measure the amount of gunpowder you need it. And then you'd pack down your gunpowder and then pull it into the rifle with a ramrod. Then you'd pull back the hammer and take something called a percussion cap and you'd fit it on the hollow metal nipple on the back of the barrel. Fold the trigger and... That was one shot. Then you had to reload which meant pouring out new gunpowder, stuffing the gunpowder and the new bullet down with the ramrod,
这里是99%隐形节目。我是罗曼·马尔斯。假设你生活在1860年之前的某个时候，你想开枪射击一支步枪。首先，你需要把火药倒进火药池里，以测量你需要的火药量。然后你需要把火药压实，接着用通条把它塞进枪膛。然后你拉回击锤，拿一个叫作底火的东西，把它安在枪管后部的空心金属奶嘴上。扣动扳机，然后……这就开了一枪。接着你必须重新装填，这意味着倒出新火药，用通条把火药和新子弹塞下去，
pulling back the hammer, putting a new percussion cap on the nipple, and then you could shoot again. The whole process took at least as long as it just took for me to describe it, and as you can imagine, this was all really inconvenient if someone was shooting at you. But then came the Winchester Repeater Rifle. That's reporter Nina Gensler-Debs. The Winchester 1866 Repeater Rif rifle was a thing of beauty. Nicknamed the yellow boy for its bright brass receiver, the gun was sleek, gleaming, and deadly. You could fire off 15 shots in just over 10 seconds. And the Winchester repeater arrived on the market just in time
拉回击锤，在奶嘴上放一个新的底火，然后你就可以再次射击了。整个过程至少和我刚才描述的时间一样长。正如你可以想象的那样，如果有人在向你开枪，这一切都非常不方便。但随后，温彻斯特连发步枪问世了。那是记者尼娜·冈斯勒-戴布斯。1866年温彻斯特连发步枪是一件美丽的作品。因为其明亮的黄铜机匣，这把枪被称为“黄金男孩”，它线条流畅、闪闪发光且致命。你可以在短短10秒内射出15发子弹。而温彻斯特连发步枪恰好在
for the rise of Western expansion. The huge sweep of manifest destiny and people migrating to the Western part of North America. That's Mary Joignoffo, a California historian at Deanza College in Cupertino. That weapon became a source of survival and protection for people. The next iteration of the Winchester Repeater, the 1873 model, was an even bigger hit. It was lighter, more accurate, and it became synonymous with westward expansion. It came to be known as the gun that won the West, but probably only by people who think they won the West. The Winchester Rifle Company was very successful.
西部大开发兴起之时进入市场。这是“昭昭天命”的巨大浪潮，人们向北美西部迁移。这是德安扎学院库比蒂诺分校的加州历史学家玛丽·乔伊诺福所说的话。那把武器成了人们生存和保护的源泉。温彻斯特连发步枪的下一个迭代版本，即1873年型号，取得了更大的成功。它更轻、更准确，并成为了向西扩张的代名词。它后来被称为“赢得西部的枪”，但这可能只有那些认为自己赢了西部的人才会这么认为。温彻斯特步枪公司非常成功。
The most successful arms company in America in the late 19th century. The Winchester family became fabulously wealthy. They lived together in this palatial mansion in New Haven, Connecticut. They were harmonious, rich, and happy. And to make matters happier, William Winchester, the heir to the family business, and fortune, married the girl next door, the beautiful and intelligent Sarah Pardy, and in 1866, Sarah gave birth to a daughter, Annie. And then came a string of terrible tragedies.
它是19世纪后期美国最成功的武器公司。温彻斯特家族变得极其富有。他们一起住在康涅狄格州纽黑文这座富丽堂皇的豪宅里。他们和谐、富有而且快乐。为了让生活更快乐，家族生意和财富的继承人威廉·温彻斯特娶了隔壁美丽的女孩、聪明伶俐的莎拉·帕迪。1866年，莎拉生下一个女儿，名叫安妮。随后却迎来了一连串可怕的悲剧。
They found that baby Annie couldn't absorb protein. And even with all the money in the world, Sarah couldn't stop her daughter from starving to death before her eyes. Then five years later, Sarah's beloved husband, William, passed away from tuberculosis. He was only 43 years old. After losing her husband, Sarah Winchester then lost her father-in-law and her eldest sister. Sarah was now alone. Half a lifetime of loneliness lay ahead of her. That's the voice of the iconic black and white film actress Lillian Gish.
他们发现婴儿安妮无法吸收蛋白质。尽管拥有世上所有的金钱，莎拉还是无法阻止女儿在自己眼前饿死。五年后，莎拉挚爱的丈夫威廉因结核病去世。他年仅43岁。在失去了丈夫之后，莎拉·温彻斯特又失去了公公和长姐。莎拉现在孤身一人。半辈子的孤独在她面前铺展开来。那是黑白电影标志性女演员莉莲·吉什的声音。
She's narrating an old documentary about Sarah Winchester with plenty of dramatic flame. And it was in that same year 18, that friends trying to consult Sarah advised her to seek the services of a well-known Boston medium. Mr. Adam Coons. And as the legend goes, through this medium, Sarah was able to contact her deceased husband William. But William had some bad news. Her husband's voice told her that she would always be haunted by the spirits of those who had been killed by the winter-st arrive. bad news.
她正在配音一部关于莎拉·温彻斯特的老纪录片，其中带有大量的戏剧性色彩。正是在同一年，即18几年，试图咨询莎拉的朋友们建议她寻求波士顿一位知名灵媒的服务，即亚当·库恩斯先生。正如传说所言，通过这位灵媒，莎拉得以联系到她已故的丈夫威廉。但威廉带来了一些坏消息。她丈夫的声音告诉她，她将永远被那些被温彻斯特击毙的人的亡灵所纠缠。这是个坏消息。
Someone please give this poor widow a break. He now instructed her to placate them by building a structure that would never be completed. A house to which rooms would constantly be added to provide shelter for the ever increasing number of Winchester rifle victims. Finally, he told her that by doing what he had prescribed, she would gain immortality. Winchester rifles had killed a lot of people. If Sarah was to appease their ghosts, she would need to build a very, very big house.
求求谁来给这位可怜的寡妇放个假吧。他现在指示她通过建造一座永远无法完工的建筑来安抚他们。这是一座将不断增建房间的房子，为不断增加的温彻斯特步枪受害者提供庇护。最后，他告诉她，通过做他所规定的事情，她将获得永生。温彻斯特步枪杀死了很多人。如果莎拉要平息他们的幽灵，她就需要建造一所非常非常大的房子。
And she had the money to do it. Having inherited her late husband's stock in the rifle company, she was now one of the wealthiest people in the country. And where better to build an ever expanding structure than in the wide open west, California. Sarah left New Haven to begin a new in California. She bought an eight room farmhouse in San Jose
她有钱这样做。继承了已故丈夫在步枪公司的股票后，她现在成为了全国最富有的人之一。还有什么地方比开阔的西部加利福尼亚更适合建造一座不断扩张的建筑呢？莎拉离开纽黑文，在加州开始了新的生活。她在圣何塞买了一座八个房间的农舍，
and dove into the remodeling project head first. At any given time, there might have been a dozen people working on the house. Carpenters, tile-setters, painters, electricians. Some reports estimate that her house swelled from 8 to 26 rooms in the first six months. And others claim there was no end to the construction. That Sarah Winchester's crew worked on the house in rotating shifts 24 hours a day for 38 years. As the construction marched forward, the house became a tangled maze of halls and a mash-up of turrets and stained glass windows. You know it has a kind of haunted mansion quality. That's architectural historian Mitchell Schwartzer. Dores that lead nowhere, you know, staircases that stop halfway.
并一头扎进改造项目中。在任何时候，房子里可能都有十多个人在工作。木匠、瓷砖工、油漆工、电工。一些报道估计，在头六个月里，她的房子从8个房间扩大到了26个房间。另一些人则声称建设永无止境。莎拉·温彻斯特的团队以轮班制在房子里工作，一天24小时，持续了38年。随着建设的推进，这座房子变成了一个由大厅组成的错综复杂的迷宫，以及塔楼和彩绘玻璃窗的混合体。你知道它有一种闹鬼豪宅的特质。建筑历史学家米歇尔·施瓦茨尔这样说道。通往虚无的门，你知道的，中途停下的楼梯。
And because she built over so many years, the house was also a wild combination of architectural styles. You know, every five years or so, there was a kind of new movement, new types of ornament, curves are introduced in the 1890s. But for a long time, no one was able to see the hodgepodge of styles and ornaments in this house except Sarah Winchester. Well, Sarah and her staff of 18 house servants, 13 carpenters, 8 to 10 gardeners and two private chauffeurs. Because Sarah Winchester kept to herself.
由于她建造了多年，这座房子也是建筑风格的疯狂结合。你知道的，每隔五年左右，就会有一种新的运动，新类型的装饰，1890年代引入了曲线。但在很长一段时间里，除了莎拉·温彻斯特之外，没有人能够看到这座房子里风格和装饰的大杂烩。嗯，还有莎拉和她的18名家政仆人、13名木匠、8到10名园丁和两名私人司机。因为莎拉·温彻斯特离群索居。
Mrs. Winchester did not entertain, and she did not open her doors to herself. Mrs. Winchester did not entertain and she did not open her doors to visitors. Supposedly Sarah Winchester was also always shrouded in a veil. And she never spoke to strangers or members of the press who inquired about her odd building endeavor. And because she didn't respond, they started formulating their own suggestions. Maybe she's superstitious. Maybe she feels guilty that all that money came from guns. Maybe she feels like if she keeps building she'll never die. And so those little stories became the factual analysis of Mrs. Winchester. It's unclear how much of the Sarah Winchester legend is true. We don't know whether she commune with ghosts, or at least thought she was communing with
温彻斯特太太不搞社交，也不向自己敞开大门。温彻斯特太太不搞社交，也不向访客敞开大门。据说莎拉·温彻斯特也总是披着面纱。她从不与询问她奇怪建筑工作的陌生人或记者交谈。因为她不回应，他们开始提出他们自己的建议。也许她很迷信。也许她感到内疚，因为所有的钱都来自枪支。也许她觉得如果她继续建造，她就永远不会死。因此，这些小故事成了温彻斯特太太的事实分析。目前尚不清楚莎拉·温彻斯特的传奇有多少是真实的。我们不知道她是否与幽灵交流，或者至少认为她正在与
ghosts, or whether she built her huge house to placate them, or whether she felt guilty about her fortune coming from guns. But after her death, those legends and rumors about her have lived on. After Sarah's death, an entrepreneur named John H. Brown saw the possibility in the old decrepit estate. In 1923, he reopened Mrs. Winchester's property as the Winchester Mystery House, and ever since it's been the subject of all kinds of pseudo-documentaries on haunted houses. Said to be inhabited by ghosts, and inspired by madness, it has the deranged design of
幽灵交流，或者她是否建造了巨大的房子来安抚他们，或者她是否对她的财富来自枪支感到内疚。但在她死后，关于她的那些传奇和谣言一直流传下来。莎拉死后，一个名叫约翰·H·布朗的企业家看到了这座古老破败庄园的潜力。1923年，他将温彻斯特太太的财产重新开放为温彻斯特神秘屋，从那以后，它一直是各种关于鬼屋的伪纪录片的题材。据说那里住着幽灵，灵感来自疯狂，它有着
a carnival funhouse. The Winchester Mystery House was built on here. When I walked in my, on my head, I got chills. The workers that built this place, they're still building it on the other side. For $33, you can buy a ticket and tour Sarah Winchester's house. My name is Maggie and I will be your guide today on this 65-minute tour Sarah Winchester's house. My name is Maggie and I will be your guide today on this 65 minute tour of Mrs. Winchester's beautiful 160-rubic touring mansion.
狂乱的设计，就像嘉年华的游乐屋。温彻斯特神秘屋就是在这里建造的。当我走进去时，我的头上起了鸡皮疙瘩。建造这个地方的工人们，他们仍在另一边建造它。花33美元，你就可以买张票参观莎拉·温彻斯特的房子。我叫玛吉，今天我将担任你的导游，进行这次为期65分钟的莎拉·温彻斯特房子的参观。我叫玛吉，今天我将担任你的导游，进行这次为期65分钟的温彻斯特太太美丽的160个房间的豪宅之旅。
I brought my family there. We'd drove an hour, we waited in line, we sold out a whole lot of money for tickets because we'd never been there in some Bay Area landmark. And is California historical landmark? No, we're 868. If you have a look at that black and white photo right there, the tour points out all the bizarre things about the house, like the staircases that lead to nowhere. We have our door to a wall, a window to a wall, a staircase to nowhere, and even a door to nowhere. And they like to point out that Ms. Winchester
我带我的家人去了那里。我们驱车一个小时，排队等候，花了很多钱买门票，因为我们从来没有去过某个湾区地标。而且是加州历史地标？不，我们是868号。如果你看一下那张黑白照片，导游会指出房子里所有奇异的事情，比如通往虚无的楼梯。我们有一堵墙的门，一堵墙的窗户，通往虚无的楼梯，甚至还有通往虚无的门。他们喜欢指出温彻斯特女士
hid the number 13 all around the house. If you count the blue and amber stones, you will count 13 stones. out that Nizwin Chester hid the number 13 all around the house. But the highlight of the tour is definitely the Seyons room. This is the Seyons room. Which sits in the middle of the house. This is where Sarah supposedly received directions from the spirits. Legend has it, Mrs. Winchester would come up here every night to speak to the spirits of those killed by the Winchester rifle.
把数字13藏在房子的各处。如果你数一数蓝色和琥珀色的石头，你会数出13块石头。指出温彻斯特女士把数字13藏在房子的各处。但这次参观的亮点绝对是降神室。这就是降神室。它位于房子的正中央。据说莎拉就是在这里接受来自灵魂的指示。传说温彻斯特太太每天晚上都会来这里，与被温彻斯特步枪杀死的人的灵魂对话。
They seem to be selling the story of the haunted house and of the haunted Mrs. Winchester and a lot of people seem to be buying it, but not everyone. The mythology about her is not only insulting to her, it's insulting to me as a consumer of popular culture. It insults a person's intelligence. That's Mary Jo Agnato again, and she doesn't believe the haunted Mrs. Winchester legends. She wrote a book about Sarah Winchester that challenges some of the myths about her. Sarah herself didn't write a memoir or speak to the press, but Mary Jo did find documents
他们似乎在兜售鬼屋和闹鬼的温彻斯特太太的故事，很多人似乎买账，但并非所有人。关于她的神话不仅对她是一种侮辱，对我这个流行文化消费者来说也是一种侮辱。它侮辱了一个人的智力。这是玛丽·乔·阿格纳托的再次发言，她不相信闹鬼的温彻斯特太太的传说。她写了一本关于莎拉·温彻斯特的书，挑战了关于她的一些神话。莎拉本人没有写回忆录或向媒体发言，但玛丽·乔确实找到了文件，
that helped her understand who the real Sarah Winchester may have been. There were incredible original sources that hadn't been used by anybody else before. Letters that she wrote correspondents with her attorney, property records. After pouring through documents, Mary Jo has come to believe that a lot of the really strange things that we see today and that are emphasized in the mythology about Sarah Winchester are completely explainable. The stairs to nowhere, for example, they probably did lead somewhere once. Rooms were constantly being tweaked and remodeled.
这帮助她了解真实的莎拉·温彻斯特可能是谁。有一些其他人以前没有使用过的令人难以置信的原始资料。她写的信、与律师的通信、财产记录。在翻阅了大量文件后，玛丽·乔开始相信，我们在今天看到的、并在关于莎拉·温彻斯特的神话中被强调的许多真正奇怪的事情，其实完全是可以解释的。例如，通往虚无的楼梯，它们曾经可能确实通往某个地方。房间不断地被微调和改造。
Plus the 1906 earthquake had a major effect. There are no original blueprints for the house, but we do know that the earthquake destroyed the front of the mansion and the third and fourth stories. She felt like the defects of the house really came to the fore in the 1906 earthquake. And so she kind of was chagrined at her own workmanship that this would happen. Instead of rebuilding, Sarah had workers clear away the rubble and make the place safe, and then just boarded up the front of the house. So it's very possible that the stairs led to a room that got destroyed in the quake.
再加上1906年的地震产生了重大影响。这所房子没有原始蓝图，但我们确实知道地震摧毁了豪宅的前部以及三层和四层。她觉得房子的缺陷在1906年的地震中真正显现出来了。因此，对于发生这种事，她对自己做工感到有些懊恼。莎拉没有重建，而是让工人们清理瓦砾并使这个地方安全，然后直接把房子的正面用木板封起来。所以很有可能楼梯通往一个在地震中被摧毁的房间。
As for all those thirteenths, Mary Jo doesn't put a lot of stock in them. And she believes that some of them might not be from Sarah Winchester. A couple of the men who worked on the house, they stated in the 1920s that those references to the number 13 were added after her death. As to whether Sarah Winchester conducted sances in her supposed sance room, it's possible. Spiritualism and sances were actually fairly common practice in Sarah Winchester's time, but still Mary Jo finds it unlikely partly because of the location of the room in the middle of the house.
至于所有那些13，玛丽·乔并不太在意。她相信其中一些可能不是来自莎拉·温彻斯特。几个在房子里工作的工人在20世纪20年代表示，那些对数字13的引用是在她死后才添加的。至于莎拉·温彻斯特是否在她所谓的降神室里进行过降神会，这是可能的。精神主义和降神会在莎拉·温彻斯特的时代实际上相当普遍，但玛丽·乔仍然觉得这不太可能，部分原因是该房间位于房子的正中间。
Anybody who knows about spiritualism or Sanchez know that those are really public affairs, social affairs at the very least, if not public. And you would have that in your front parlor. Then again, Sarah was a very private person, so maybe she did her sayances alone. The ranch foreman also stated that he had actually stayed in that room, and it was not related to any kind of spiritual or superstitious events at all. And lastly, in the popular legend about Sarah Winchester,
任何了解精神主义或降神会的人都知道，这些真的是公共事务，至少是社交事务，如果不是完全公开的话。你会把它放在你的前客厅里。话又说回来，莎拉是一个非常注重隐私的人，所以也许她独自进行了降神。农场工头也表示，他实际上曾在那间房里住过，这与任何形式的精神或迷信事件完全无关。最后，在关于莎拉·温彻斯特的流行传说中，
her whole building endeavor was set in motion after seeing a medium by the name of Adam Coombs, who had supposedly put her in touch with her dead husband. But Mary Jo gained access to a list of mediums and spiritualists that would have been practicing in New England during Sarah Winchester's lifetime. The name that's usually associated with having seen Winchester is not there. Adam Coombs may never have existed at all.
她所有的建筑工作都是在拜访了一位名叫亚当·库姆斯的灵媒之后开始的，据说这位灵媒让她与死去的丈夫取得了联系。但玛丽·乔查到了一份在莎拉·温彻斯特有生之年在新英格兰执业的灵媒和精神主义者名单。通常与见过温彻斯特有关的名字并不在上面。亚当·库姆斯可能根本就不存在。
There are some things we'll never know about Sarah Winchester, but what Mary Jo does feel like we can know for sure is that Sarah wasn't out of touch with reality. On the contrary, she was rational and savvy. This is a woman so far ahead of her time in financial matters, in her real estate investment, in her bond portfolio. It's remarkable. It's really remarkable.
有些关于莎拉·温彻斯特的事我们永远不会知道，但玛丽·乔确实觉得我们可以确切知道的是，莎拉并没有与现实脱节。相反，她很理性且精明。这是一个在财务事务、房地产投资、债券组合方面远远超越她那个时代的女性。这太了不起了。真的太了不起了。
So why does a financially savvy forward-thinking woman build such a crazy, never-ending house? Mary Jo has a different theory. No ghosts involved. She was an architect wannabe. Sarah Winchester wanted to be an architect. She loved doing, building, experimenting. And I love that theory. Sarah Winchester lived at a time when...
那么，一个精通财务、具有前瞻性的女性为什么要建造这样一座疯狂的、永无止境的房子呢？玛丽·乔有一个不同的理论。没有鬼魂参与。她是一个立志成为建筑师的人。莎拉·温彻斯特想成为一名建筑师。她喜欢做、建造、实验。我喜欢这个理论。莎拉·温彻斯特生活的时代……
It was highly unusual to have women architects. And she wasn't licensed. So her own house was the perfect place, the only place really, for her to practice architecture and it became her playground. Sometimes in the middle of a project, she'd lose interest and move on to something else. From all this, emerged an odd and frenetic confluence of architecture, but her house isn't only a collection of oddities. There are some legitimately innovative elements too. There's a salarium with a zinc floor. It doesn't rest, and it's tilted for the water to run off and be used in the garden. There are also these
有女建筑师是非常罕见的。而且她没有执照。所以她自己的房子是完美的地方，实际上也是唯一可以让她练习建筑的地方，它成了她的游乐场。有时在项目进行到一半时，她会失去兴趣并转向其他事情。从这一切中，涌现出了一种奇异而狂热的建筑融合，但她的房子不仅仅是奇珍异宝的集合。也有一些真正创新的元素。有一个带锌地板的日光浴室。它不会生锈，并且是倾斜的，以便水流走并用于花园。还有这些
amazing zigzagging stairs that instead of going up at a steep pitch, rise and shallower increments. that instead of going up at a steep pitch, rise in shallower increments. Sarah Winchester had debilitating arthritis, and these stairs made it possible for her to move about her house. The legend says that Sarah and her crew worked on her house 24 hours a day for 38 years, and that upon hearing of her death, her work crew finally set down their hammers and walked off the job. This is most likely an exaggeration, but the house was certainly a project that consumed Mrs.
惊人的之字形楼梯，它们不是以陡峭的坡度上升，而是以更平缓的增量上升。它们不是以陡峭的坡度上升，而是以更平缓的增量上升。莎拉·温彻斯特患有使人虚弱的关节炎，这些楼梯使她能够在房子里走动。传说莎拉和她的团队一天24小时为她的房子工作了38年，在得知她的死讯后，她的工作团队终于放下锤子，罢工了。这很可能是一种夸张，但这座房子无疑是一个消耗了温彻斯特太太
Winchester's attention for decades. Finally, he told her that by doing what he had prescribed, she would gain immortality. And of course, she didn't gain immortality from all of her building as the spirits had supposedly promised, but she did live into her 80s. In the end, whatever her motivations were, Sarah Winchester built a house with over 150 rooms, 2,000 doors, 47 fireplaces, 40 bedrooms, 40 staircases, 17 chimneys, 13 bathrooms, 6 kitchens, 3 elevators, 2 basements, and 1 shower. And spent nearly all of her life being an architect. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Ninet Gunsler Dabs, with a re-travelman Katie
数十年精力的项目。最后，他告诉她，通过做他所规定的事情，她将获得永生。当然，正如灵魂们据称所承诺的那样，她并没有从所有的建筑中获得永生，但她确实活到了80多岁。最后，无论她的动机是什么，莎拉·温彻斯特建造了一座拥有150多个房间、2000扇门、47个壁炉、40间卧室、40个楼梯、17个烟囱、13间浴室、6个厨房、3部电梯、2个地下室和1个淋浴间的房子。并且几乎把她一生所有的时光都用来当建筑师。99%隐形本周由尼娜·冈斯勒-戴布斯制作，搭档凯蒂
Mingle, Sam Greenspan, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 Local Public Radio, K-A-L-W in San Francisco and produced at the offices of Arxine, an architecture and interiors firm in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook, we're all on Twitter, Tumblr, Instagram, and Spotify and you can listen to every single episode of 99% Invisible at 99pi.org. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
明格尔、萨姆·格林斯潘以及我罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山91.7地方公共广播电台KALW的一个项目，并在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心的一家建筑和室内设计公司Arxine的办公室制作。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞该节目，我们也在Twitter、Tumblr、Instagram和Spotify上，你可以在99pi.org上收听99%隐形的每一集节目。来自PRX。该剧集尚无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可发表评论。